these migrants hit rocks
and capsized off lanzarote in spain's
canary islands
they had travelled 1500 kilometers in a
small fishing boat from north africa
young men set out full of optimism to
the tourist paradise
eight drowned in their quest on tuesday
hundreds have suffered the same fate
in the last month in 24 hours
17 boats were intercepted off the canary
islands
450 people were rescued with the search
continuing into the following day
more than seventeen thousand migrants
have arrived here this year
it's a one thousand percent spike on
2019
politicians blame the economic fallout
of the coronavirus pandemic
and opportunistic traffickers for the
surge
the italian and spanish prime ministers
discuss the crisis on wednesday
border controls of the italian and
spanish governments are efficient and
effective
the problem is what we do with these
human beings that are trafficked by
mafias
that run the risk of dying in this case
for example in the atlantic
as a consequence of trying to reach the
canary islands
the european union has struggled to come
up with a plan
which eases the burden on the
mediterranean countries taking most of
the strain
we want to work so that the mechanism of
responsibility at a european level is
met with solidarity
and we need to work in order to have
effective mechanisms on a european level
because it can't be the country of the
first arrival that bears the burden of
all the migratory flows
back on the canary islands shelters are
stretched beyond capacity
spain says it will provide more tents
hotels are being turned into temporary
accommodation
but it's hard to keep up more migrants
have arrived in november
than the last four years combined
charlotte ballas
al jazeera